[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
did it happen are we live I think so
I think you're right oh my God oh my God
that wasn't even ready I was like dick
in my hand not ready hey kids there you
go
Smith is back you just saw behind the
curtain [ __ ] baffled Kev Smith like
where are we what's going on now
performative Kev Smith is back man
welcome ladies and gentlemen to another
edition of fat man beyond I am Kevin
Smith I am Mark Bernard
hey oh uh I am broadcasting from my
comic book store Jay and Silent Bob's
secret stash I realized something was
wrong I don't have a movie hat and I'm
like do we sell them here
because we sell a lot of [ __ ] here Mark
um but I think they sold out of movie
hats and I feel so weird doing the show
without my movie hat on what and you're
wearing like an actual coat and [ __ ]
yeah I'm like the robe is weird I'm
throwing the audience the audience is
like what the [ __ ] the the a the show
started on time kinda
B he's not wearing the stupid [ __ ]
hat and he's wearing a grown-up jacket
he's wearing his his [ __ ] you get
this shirt right here at the secret
stash kids see that rack right there
get One of These Fine [ __ ]
kriel shares that's the station that Mr
svening worked for
in Mallrats and uh Randall wears that
shirt in in clerks three as you can see
behind me there's always a wall of pops
when I do the show at home
now there's two gigantic [ __ ] pops
that's right outside of the Funko store
this is the only place you'll find
ridiculously oversized ego feeding pops
look how cute do you want to see like
[ __ ]
I don't have the proper shorts on so but
I'll just stand next to them and see
what it looks like
as long as there are shorts everybody
wins
I didn't realize how deep this set was
it's pretty deep set my friend you're
not on the volume we can bring so many
[ __ ]
animals [ __ ] elephants whatever the
[ __ ] right in goddamn circus behind me
man
how's everybody doing out there ladies
and gentlemen welcome
uh to fat man beyond as we said [ __ ]
already and stuff uh Mark's in Los
Angeles uh I'm currently in New Jersey
um I was uh I've been on the road with
the convenience tour which has been
[ __ ] Bliss like every night everyone
makes me feel like so smart and clever
and [ __ ] talented it's so awesome
um our biggest show was an 1800 Cedar in
Denver sold out [ __ ] oh [ __ ] son and
this movie with 1800 people crying at
once it's cathartic the last one you
know there's a lot of laughs in the
movie when laughs are happening it's
amazing but like when it gets emotional
holy [ __ ] so um then we went to uh
Seattle we had two sold out shows in
Seattle we were just in
Salem Oregon last night
I'm here in Jersey because we closed on
the movie theater today it became
smodcast Castle Cinemas so I'm telling
you this from my comic book store Jay
and Silent Bob secret stash in Red Bank
New Jersey been open for 25 years and if
you do want one of these [ __ ] fine
ass
carry all shirts you go to Jay and
Silent bob.com and there's a separate
link for the secret stash you can only
get it at the secret step
um I'm here in my secret session
announcing that I now own a movie
theater in Atlantic Highlands New Jersey
Amir
uh well 20 minutes for people who drive
normally a mere 12 minutes from here for
me that's how fast they got here tonight
um 12 minutes away at Atlantic Highlands
New Jersey
Ernie had the sign put in I posted on
Instagram
and
um it's lit up like I left there at
night it's all lit up I was just hanging
out in the movie theater I was in the
apartment upstairs uh but I was hanging
out with the kids that run the [ __ ]
theater marked 52 I'm hanging out with
the [ __ ] proletariat son
kids kids I'm hanging out with the plebs
and we're having a blast we're [ __ ] I'm
I'm I'm fitting right in mark
does Mr Drummond know that you [ __ ]
we've been let out of a fabulous Mansion
yeah I'm like hey kids [ __ ] you want
to hang out with a 52 year old they're
like I guess we have to you're our boss
now and [ __ ]
um there's uh they're they're adorable
the kids around the theater but they're
[ __ ] children like you know not like
just I'm not saying that dismissively
I'm just
painfully aware of how [ __ ] old I am
but I told the kids tonight I said look
nothing's going to change except well
here the things are going to change
you're all going to start working on
wearing hockey jerseys that's the
official like [ __ ] outfit
um I said but you're also going to do a
thing I'm gonna steal from the ArcLight
I said they're gone they ain't coming
back anymore
they used to have at the beginning every
screening some [ __ ] Usher come down
and be like hey man my name is [ __ ]
Bob and this is you're gonna watch Wild
at Heart [ __ ] you know David Lynch is
a genius whatever the [ __ ] I was a
random pulsar
a very deep cut but you know they say
some [ __ ] and then tell you like if
anything's [ __ ] wrong come talk to
one of us or whatever
I'm like we're totally [ __ ] stealing
that I said so every one of you kids is
gonna have to like go up and intro the
movies and they were all like into it
they weren't like oh man and so Riley
was like the girl she was tick-tocking
last time I was there I was like you're
in charge of the [ __ ] smod Castle
Cinema tick tock I want you Tick-Tock in
every one of those intros
because we'll have like a thousand
[ __ ] intros for all sorts of movies
and [ __ ]
um
so it's it's fun oh my God it's fun I
ain't even owned it a day and I'm having
a good time I was just there
clerks three is starting [ __ ] five
people came to see it on a Wednesday
night not bad but I was able to go [ __ ]
I said I walked into the theater I sat
literally in front row I sat right in
front of him I was like kids
I could do the whole movie for you like
before it even begins I Know It real
well and we chit-chatted and [ __ ] as
when I live upstairs I was gonna troll
down to every even if it's not my movie
Mark I'm gonna fall down and be like in
my pajamas in my robe be like how's
everyone doing man like this [ __ ]
all right here's the movie
so this is I cracked the code
like I love that your version of Batman
is I'm going to live over my movie
theater and when things get dodgy I'm
going to go down the back pull into the
theater give himself some problems I I
do have a secret elevator that goes from
my apartment into the theater Mark into
the theater isn't that crazy I'm telling
you I feel like Tom Hanks in big
my apartment's not as nice as his but
remember when he got that [ __ ] Rich
ass apartment with a trampoline in it
and [ __ ]
oh my God living above a movie theater
dialed my clock back like at least 10
[ __ ] years man I've it's gonna be fun
it's gonna be good times cut to me two
years from now I'm going like we're in
financial ruining
why did I put it together
but for now
best decision I ever made and just like
when we announced it Mark I put up uh
you know a [ __ ] Instagram about it
today and a tweet
100 consensus nobody nobody going [ __ ]
you in your movie theater everyone loves
you when you buy a movie theater
you're everyone's friend when you buy a
movie theater Mark you can't be Elon
Musk when you buy a movie theater Mark
everyone [ __ ] just
loves you for buying a movie theater all
right people today who thanked me for
buying the movie they're like thanks for
saving this place I was like I didn't
save it it was up it was in business
Tony was running it like I just bought
it
um but man it's it's Joy anytime
the internet's like [ __ ] you and your
movies and try to [ __ ] on me or mass of
the universe that come after me again
I figured I cracked the code let's go
buy a movie theater
very expensive but it'll change the
conversation and people will stop being
mad at me and they'll be happy with me
that's that's what I'm getting out of
this whole experience I mean retail
therapy is a thing it's usually not real
estate therapy but whatever it takes
they're like you poor privileged [ __ ]
white man yeah you have to solve your
problems by buying a whole ass movie
theater yeah you shut your pie hole on
quite a new movie theater
um oh it's a blast uh but I'm back on
the road um I'm here for just we closed
today and stuff and then I'm back on the
road uh uh Friday we have a sold out
show at the Castro theater in San
Francisco and that place is [ __ ] Barn
man it's huge so that's gonna [ __ ]
rock my brother and Jerry is my my
brother-in-law uh they're gonna be there
they're out in San Francisco
for unrelated reasons so he's going to
come to the show I think Jeff Anderson's
coming to that show
um so San Francisco's sold out right
after that is Sacramento that's sold out
then we start getting into the places
that aren't sold out Mark
um we do San Diego the Balboa theater
nice we're about 400 off at this point
from selling out each one has a thousand
or more people in it but like these
theaters kind of big so the Balboa in
San Diego then we head up to Los Angeles
October 4th we do uh the ace theater the
Ace Hotel theater downtown and there's
like a couple hundred seats left for
that and stuff tickets still available
there
um and then we go to Anaheim and I think
there's tickets still available there
um but generally every place I've gone
has been like
an overwhelming sold out show and even
again the places aren't sold out it's
over a thousand people 1200 people and
stuff so it's
every night it's like going to a church
where I'm both the priest and Jesus at
the same time
um kids come out and join us it is so
[ __ ] it's a great time like the movie
works it's you know I know there's some
people online they're like oh this heads
up his ass again my head's been up my
ass since 1994 since I started the
[ __ ] job so that's not news that's
[ __ ] I was gonna say fake news that's
old news
um but my God it's like
thunderous dude like
my whole life has been about trying to
approximate the things that seem
interesting from the outside you know
for example yeah Richard link later made
slacker I was like that seems
interesting I wonder what it'd be like
to be a filmmaker and I pursued
filmmaking and now I do it I used to
love listening to Howard Stern when I
was a kid I was like what an amazing job
just sit around talk to your friends and
[ __ ] goof around I wonder what that'd
be like and that's what podcasting has
been like for me for the last you know
since 2007.
um you know stand up I was big George
Carlin fan so I was like oh man [ __ ]
what would that be like to stand on a
stage and try to be funny and I've
gotten to I've gotten a taste of so many
[ __ ] things like you know never the
real thing right like I'll never have
George Carlin's career why would I that
was his career but I know what it's like
to stand on stage be funny command the
audience and stuff like that
with clerks 3 and Jane saw and Bob
reboot with the Roadshow model that we
do and whatnot me being in the
screenings and you know forcing 12 to
1800 [ __ ] hardcore fans into a room
in one night
I I'll never make a Marvel movie and I'm
not good enough and talented enough to
make one of them Marvel movies but like
we have many moments
you know that are reminiscent of being
in a Marvel screening you know with a
bunch of people that know the material
because that's what it is the
differences between the audience of
course like they got more money and way
better characters and [ __ ] but you're
talking about two audiences who are
involved deeply involved with an ongoing
story
and so when someone shows up the [ __ ]
audience goes nuts applauding them and
[ __ ] cheering and stuff like that
um you know I I get to see the
difference from City to City what people
like applaud and like there's one scene
in the movie that like I don't want to
spoil anything but you know it's in the
third act and [ __ ] and like eight out of
16 times it's gotten [ __ ] Applause at
this moment which is really tender and I
never expected that some moments you
planned for like all the funny [ __ ] I
was like I you know I knew when you know
uh [ __ ] uh you know Jay made the joke
about like [ __ ] man we all gonna be
doing DPS I was like I knew everyone
would [ __ ] laugh some [ __ ] you don't
plan for it just [ __ ] happens and
like people having these cathartic
moments in the third Act of the movie
where they're Mass applauding some sad
things is is wonderful it's so nice to
see people
crying after a Kevin Smith movie and not
because the movie sucked because the
movie worked and [ __ ] like that so the
tour has been blessed man uh come on out
it's such a good time watching it with a
bunch of like-minded individuals every
night I feel like the Russo Brothers for
a minute or two I'm like this is what it
must have felt like for them when
[ __ ] Captain America you know when uh
Captain America caught the hammer and
the audience just [ __ ] erupted
because when Silent Bob [ __ ] speaks
in the movie I've been in both theaters
I'm not saying I'm as good as a Marvel
movie please don't [ __ ] get it
twisted and betting [ __ ] but
the Applause level just as [ __ ]
thunderous man and for that brief
Shining Moment I'm like oh that's what
it'd be like if I made a Marvel movie
cool but it's kind of a little more
satisfying because it's my [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying like
I'd be happy to make people clap using
somebody else's toys but like when they
applaud and it's my toys that I created
when I was a [ __ ] kid that feels even
better and [ __ ] so the tour has been
absolutely wonderful come on out kids
and see us if you're in California [ __ ]
we need the help uh come see us uh at
the Ace Hotel theater
um in Los Angeles October 4th uh come
see us at the Balboa theater October 2nd
in San Diego whales vagina and uh come
see us I think it's October 5th yes in
Anaheim uh we'll be I'll be chucking up
there and [ __ ] while I'm in town
I'm gonna be doing uh The Woody Show on
morning of October 3rd and then going to
do Good Day LA and then on the fifth I'm
doing the talk I did The View when I was
back East now I'm doing the talk dude
I've done them all I did The View and
the talk are there any more of the shows
I could do it
um so yeah I'll be touring until
December it looks like December 5th
right now is our last show
so what is today September 20th Jesus
I'm on the road for like two more months
and change [ __ ] so we're gonna have to
be streaming like this for the next
little while whatever it takes
whatever it takes I know I can make it
through
that's Degrassi song what was the song
that I was [ __ ] singing when we first
jumped on before the show began
um well I I was singing uh Dougie Fresh
The Show
I remember the one before that it was a
journey song
which one do you remember uh
uh it wasn't Don't Stop Believing no it
was uh Faithfully
oh thank you JC that would have bugged
me all night I was like because Mark
said how's life on the road and I said
second life
[Laughter]
you know what I went lower because I
said [ __ ] in my throat hold on
I'm going to charge you Steve Perry
Justice oh don't do that you can hurt
yourself I'm gonna do it get your old
man I'm gonna pull something doing it
but I'm gonna do it it's gonna be worth
it stick is life that's as high as I can
go yeah
[Music]
um life on the road has been absolutely
uh wonderful watching the movie over and
over uh like a play every night almost I
can do this movie in my sleep man I can
[ __ ] do every line of dialogue and
stuff I I've sometimes like I can sit
there with the kids but Josh and Liv are
the tour managers uh I could sit there
with the kids and like go like
uh cue laughter now and [ __ ] audience
goes eruption because I've seen it so
many times I know all the laughter
places is wonderful so I've been having
a good time please come out and join us
kids particularly if you're in [ __ ]
California
um and uh we're adding new shows all the
time Boston a lot of people have been
harassing me about Boston that day it's
about to get added I know a Las Vegas
state is about to get added I heard a
Connecticut date is going to get added
so
if if you don't see your city there
don't mean we're not coming yet man
we're coming all over your face neck and
[ __ ] a chest
pops
um okay
uh what about you never mind
you clearly you must have done a thing
clearly I must have also traveled the
world
uh you I saw did you do a black man
beyond I did I've done uh I've done a
couple now I did one solo one the the
first one uh since you went on tour then
we had Hawkman himself out of this Hodge
was on a pod you don't [ __ ] Garfunkel
me not what I smell here is your [ __ ]
you're hauling it you're realizing that
like I could do this with any guitar
player and [ __ ] don't don't [ __ ] oats
me man
next week and this is Victor Garber I
think is going to be on it that my God a
would break my heart but B what a stroke
of brilliance
that would certainly teach me some
[ __ ] lesson
he might do it if I was off the show you
know if I bet you would he's like look
Kevin was the only reason I want to do
it because he's such an ass he's a
[ __ ] whole ass who's an [ __ ]
you know we'll probably I've got another
one coming on the 11th of October
um with uh
that's it
making sure there's no
smoke alarm no weed detectors
my Sports Rock and Smoke hey you want to
see something you want to see a movie
star sure
who's your body kids
can you see him Barry oh you can't see
him he's blocked by a thing God damn it
can you see Jesus
there he is
Buddy Christ kids from the movie Dogma
right next to me
so every once in a while if you see me
go like Jesus Christ is because I
remember that he's right there because
he's slowly moving towards you yeah
just roll around the room
show too he just keeps getting closer
I'm like Mark I think old wooden head
old Jesus said is on his way over
uh Malcolm Barrett will be joining me
for another black man Beyond at the
Cantina we're doing a live black man
look at you [ __ ] selling tickets and
all that [ __ ] sounds like it's it could
just be me Malcolm into bartenders but
that's also just as well I'm telling you
this is your [ __ ] Paul Simon moment
this is where you're like I don't need
the other guy
no but we'll always have Central Park
that's true we get to we have one
reunion and then for the rest of my life
I'm like hey you want to do another one
of those and you're like no I'm good
we gotta go to South Africa and record
an album what
that is deep cut I mean look I'm sure
the audience is like what are you old
men rambling about we're doing Paul
Simon material kids
we're doing straight up 90s Nostalgia
[ __ ] that's 60 70s
well anyway specifically Paul Simon
going to South Africa to record an album
y'all will be recorded was called
Graceland and I was in Memphis last
weekend
yeah what was that about I saw on your
Instagram what were you doing in Memphis
uh I was at the Memphis Comic Expo
um you went to a show I went to a show
my first uh my first table in on back in
the world after a whole mess of years
and I got to sit next to your friend in
mine Ming Chen
um or occasionally Ann Arbor's oh the
main champ
that's true
because for some reason he wants to own
Ann Arbor
school there he went to school there
back in the day yeah
um here talk talk to the kids I I
gotta go find a [ __ ] hat this Hat's
bugging
I've never seen some reason I gotta I
gotta get that [ __ ] weird hat I can't
do the regular hat the regular hat makes
my head look normal
um and I also I think since last we
spoke
um Kevin and I have a thing in common in
that we both have new comic books out
Kevin has masquerade from the from the
Dark Horse Comics and I've got a book
called census which is dropping monthly
uh five issue miniseries for uh
comicsology Originals which will then be
collected by the same place that's
putting masquerade out Dark Horse Comics
um so yeah man Memphis was a good time
couldn't really sign a census it's a
digital comic now and nobody was
bringing the iPads
um but I ate a [ __ ] ton of barbecue I
had a [ __ ] ton of uh
fried chicken and donuts
he found one
oh yeah I can't find this out in the
Kevin Smith store the world's [ __ ]
I was talking about uh comic books that
uh that you and I both have new comic
books out into the world
I do and I heard you talking about the
whole thing and I grabbed my comic books
while you were talking here's Master
issue one the captain Redman cover
um over here we got uh the Masquerade
number one with the Francesco francovio
cover gorgeous
and then this is the secret stash
exclusive variant cover as drawn by uh
comic book men's Walter Flanagan the
only place you can get this kids
is here these are for you and you don't
get them Secret Sauce you can order them
from secretstash online uh what's the
book that you got out you did you you've
talked about I saw you talk about on
your social media but I don't know if
you've talked about here yeah I haven't
really uh it's a book called census well
I'm talking about Adora how [ __ ] that
was out of print you didn't even know it
I know I didn't know I told you I was
like it's out of print because Mike
zapsick here at the stash we're trying
to organize a signing for Mark and
Mike's like I can't get the books and I
was like sure you can get the books man
if I could order them from Dark Horse or
whatever [ __ ] and he's like no they're
out of print like he sold out his entire
print run
you are total seller but I guess they
reprinted they re they've gone back for
a second printing
um which thankfully will be in stores
hopefully soon if not already
um they don't tell me much unless I ask
them and I continually forget to ask
them but
um what what what went wrong I was so
happy for a second well it's a little
loose looser than the one I got at home
oh okay I mean there's a lot of free a
lot of free space and [ __ ] and that
irritates people online people like
tighten your hat you dick like I'll
literally read that in chat and be like
if it's not [ __ ] one thing it's
another with these [ __ ] cats if it's
not you know me thinking Spider-Man
should have been one of the films
nominated it's like my hat's too loose
what what can I do to [ __ ] please you
all huh
go buy another movie theater
oh good point yeah
coming soon movie theater in a town near
you bought by me to flip the
conversation
um but yes I have a new book out from
comixology called census which is about
a uh a 27 slacker in New York City who
dances a shitty want ad for a job that
involves him knocking on occasional on
random doors doors in Manhattan uh
Brooklyn Queens Staten Island and and
the Bronx
to see who's behind those doors and to
keep a census but it happens to be run
by the other world uh census agency and
it's to figure out how many demons and
monsters and cthulhus and spirit dragons
and
um crazy mythological beasts are living
in New York City
no you came up with that me and my buddy
Adam Freeman did yeah so wait is he
riding or drawn he's co-writing with me
and we have another artist named uh
Sebastian Perez
um who's doing great work he's doing the
pencils inks and colors himself who's
publishing this book
comixology Originals is doing the
digital first and then dark horse is
doing print the same thing that you did
with the Dora so this is your second
book that way my second book with them
um you're a prolific a prolific man I'm
trying my best to keep up I got one
[ __ ] comic book
and three different covers
so that's the only way I guess you could
make money in the comic book business
three different covers kids look at that
you're not complete until you got all
these masquerades uh and then quick
stops number one comes out
uh November 2nd we sell the masquerades
on tour like at one point Jordan was
like I'm gonna send a box of the comics
and I was like masquerade has nothing to
do with clerks three she's like you know
if they like you they might buy it and
so we put a box out in uh Colorado man I
signed half of them in the other half I
just left it cover price and
there they go
believe me I was at my movie theater
tonight hanging with the youth
tick-tocking with the youth and uh one
of the things I'm going to do there is
bring some graphic novels I told Mike
zap sick it was like pull together
anytime a comic book movie's coming out
and even when one's not coming out I
mean full selection of [ __ ] DC and
Marvel that have that can reference
and in the movies they put out those
treasury editions all the time those
Marvel Masterworks and [ __ ]
everyone pays by credit card now saying
this is almost a cash-free [ __ ] world
man so if they're buying popcorn they're
like oh [ __ ] I could buy The Infinity
Gauntlet
the the [ __ ] maybe they buy it and
that's one more person reading a comic
book yeah I'll have my kids when they
introduce the screenings particularly if
it's a comic book movie
if you like this it's based on X or y's
based on the Judas contract which we
sell at the concession stand
you see how we do because the secret of
the movie business Mark
you don't make any money off the movies
Studios take half the money the good
half like when you open a movie they
take like 75 of it and [ __ ] like that
it's crazy so you're really in the candy
selling business or in my case the candy
and the [ __ ]
comic book selling business I went to
the Rio theater Rio uh up in Vancouver
because we did uh
um clerks three up there and Karina owns
the theater man she was giving me tips
and [ __ ] one of them was insanely
helpful I was stealing ideas bring back
to my movie theater at the end of the
first show like they got two shows and I
at the end of the first show when
everyone leaves you know ushers sweep up
and [ __ ] they come in with [ __ ] leaf
blowers
and they just blow all that [ __ ] down to
the front and sweep it up in one full
swoop I was like that's thinking wow
that's thinking now who's got money
nurses this guy Jerry Graff he's going
nuts got five ten nurses a week no sorry
I dipped into Glengarry Glen Ross
um and not even a good rendition of it I
was approximating at errors but not well
Ed Harris
Jersey
uh Native Jersey Zone yeah apparently
it's Jersey Zone I know that because our
own dark Nate Gonzalez who does our
artwork for the shows
um he's doing this gorgeous mural for uh
the lobby of smod Castle
that features all the people who went on
to movie success who were from New
Jersey and [ __ ] Roy Scheider Jaws is
represented on the wall because Roy
Scheider is from New Jersey didn't know
that
um oh my God
you can obviously tell I'm very enthused
about this movie theater
I'm gonna be like an insufferable ass
about it we have to stop talking though
about me and my boy and we talked a
little bit about you and your [ __ ]
but we have to stop that too we do we
better [ __ ] talk about the [ __ ]
people want to hear about
and we got two two classes of [ __ ]
to talk about today we have the Andor
class of [ __ ] in that I've seen the
first four episodes you saw four I saw
two so far yeah and then what is the
other class of [ __ ] uh the other
class of [ __ ] is news that we can
talk about because there's not a ton of
news but it's big news let's start with
the news because it's so [ __ ]
exciting
and yet at the same time not surprising
one iota
when it happened I was like
wow oh of course like how did I not see
that [ __ ] coming
um Mark is an old news out kids and so
he gathers up the news and
he he's using it he's newsy
he's got he's he's newsy he's one of the
newsy neighbors that you see in the 60s
and 70s sitcoms he's like Edna Kravitz
or whatever the [ __ ] anyway
he's always collecting he's like Agatha
all along
Mark collects the news Mark's going to
hit you across your [ __ ] face with
the big floppy wet dick of news hit him
mark
uh well yesterday it seems that you know
it made tonight's show necessary when uh
Mr Ryan Reynolds went onto the social
media talking you know just in general
about hey man you know Deadpool 3 is
coming we're working really hard at it
I've been been Plumbing the uh my soul
to figure out exactly what it's going to
be
um but it came up empty he didn't know
what to give the crowd to to make him
happy so then he just uh just leans over
shoulder and says hey here do you want
to play Wolverine one more time and Hugh
Jackman is walking through the
background and says yeah sure Ryan and
then it walks upstairs because they live
together like it's a sitcom
Wolverine will be in in uh in Deadpool
3.
um
fantastic news
um I saw they put up a second video
where they were like you know talking
about how
you know we got we know you have a lot
of questions
Wolverine died in Logan that's not
changing but that movie takes place and
2029 or whatever the [ __ ] and then they
go to tell you what it is and they just
played [ __ ] wake me up
and uh there was one moment where where
[ __ ] you Jackman like Wolverine
clawed into Ryan Reynold's head and then
he was doing the like [ __ ] ah
um how long do we need to live to see
this magic what's the new goal to stay
alive stay alive
how long do we have to live mark You're
Gonna live two more years my friend
September 6 2024 is the release date for
Deadpool 3. oh that's legit almost two
years from now yeah yeah
that means I gotta make another movie to
kill the time and [ __ ] all right sorry
kids and I have to make another movie
Force another movie on you thanks Marvel
playing Marvel and [ __ ] kicking their
[ __ ] this is a Marvel movie right this
is the first Deadpool under Marvel and
that's why they thank Kevin feige in the
second trailer they do indeed yeah
um it is yeah because Disney bought Fox
and so now that brings all of the fox
things under the same corporate umbrella
which is how you get Wolverine in a
Deadpool movie and and everybody wins
talk about the stroke of Brilliance in
terms of it's Deadpool 3 and we all love
Deadpool and we all [ __ ] want for
Deadpool too more or less
um you know there's a good chance we
were all going to go for Deadpool 3 but
man if you want to [ __ ] clinch that
you want to make it a sure [ __ ] thing
you want to no way home that [ __ ] they
just figured it out now my question to
you and this is not a like I ain't a
complaint but I ain't stretch the
imagination but
where do you go from here
like how many times can you
close the past on the present
before you run out of [ __ ] I mean I
guess sky's the limit
I mean like you know moments like this
they're getting a lot of bites at the
X-Men apple right like as much as
they're like we're creating our own
mutants they are like giving Victory
runs and milking the [ __ ] Fox X-Men
for all they're worth we had Professor X
show up in uh Multiverse of Madness the
whole ass Wolverine and Deadpool movie
it's a great time to be alive man but
like
is it like
how do you keep them down on the farm
once they've seen Perry
I mean it's to a certain degree Marvel
is absolutely introducing mutants in in
a in a slightly less obvious way
in the other stuff I mean kamalacan is a
mutant
um in the in the margins of a She-Hulk
web page you got to see men with claws
destroys bar
you know like little bits and pieces of
dropping that they're going to be
mutants apparently you know Namor is
legitimating and uh Ms Marvel's a mutant
as well and this model is immune so they
are introducing the idea of mutants into
into the MCU I wonder if and they will
100 at some point introduce the expat or
the mutants or whatever they can end up
calling
but we will see you Jean Gray we will
see you Scott Summers but we'll see a
beast we will see a probably a Logan and
probably a new Logan because
Hugh Jackman lovely as he is is also 50
something years old
um so you're not going to build the new
version of the X-Men around him so is
this is Deadpool 3 a little pocket
universe is it its own little weird
offshoot of the MCU
um or is it MCU Prime and are we just
going to is it all going to be folded
into the same thing is this is this the
Multiverse that then gets folded as with
everything else when we get to the
secret Wars I just assume Multiverse but
talk about a glow up like I love the
cable story and I love Josh Brolin when
he goes funny
but Jesus stroke of Brilliance pulling
this one and again how did we not see it
coming they're always [ __ ] around
with each other in videos and [ __ ] like
that but I guess we're all so literal
right because we're like well
Wolverine's dead and he said he's done
playing Wolverine and everyone forgot
the very simple concept of money
you know it doesn't make the world go
round but it definitely greases the
wheels there's no way he's doing another
kindness is hard I'll tell you that
[ __ ] much uh no it's if I'm him I
mean it has no judgment on his character
that's me playing you Hugh Jackman like
an avatar because if I was him I'd be
like
Trump
and then they dump
a pile of [ __ ] one dollar bills
tightly bound
on his [ __ ] lawn and then take off
and [ __ ]
yeah it's very much the bring me the
standard Robert Downey Jr deal and
there'd be they'd be dumb not to do it
like I applaud it whatever you got to
pay that [ __ ] to put on the claws one
more time
because you're right man like this is
like this is I think they're Victory
lapping with these characters that they
just acquired because they're getting
ready to launch their own mutants and
like you said I don't think you know as
much as we all love Hugh Jackman I think
MCU is probably going to be predicated
on younger cats playing these characters
and whatnot but we live in a Multiverse
now
uh in the movies so why wouldn't you
grab [ __ ] why wouldn't you pay
anything
to get you [ __ ] Jackman to come back
to be Wolverine again I mean think about
is there anybody else you could do that
for who would matter that much
he's it
characters uh and the actors he's the
gold standard in terms of like
you know oh my God this [ __ ] is back
like I'm not saying everyone didn't
matter and [ __ ] but like you know you
get
[ __ ] uh fonka Jensen back for a cameo
you don't build the whole movie around
around her but Hugh Jackman as Wolverine
even my mother knows that Hugh Jackman
is [ __ ] Wolverine not not [ __ ]
Wolverine but that Jack Hugh Jackman is
Wolverine yeah
I'll pay to see that [ __ ] Hugh
Jackman they'd have to back up two money
trucks indeed
it's smart play man it's smart and we're
all going to benefit like there's no way
this movie sucks no way
so yay yay yay for all of it except the
two-year wait which seems a little
egregious but as Mark says as a judge
I'll allow it
um so that was the uh that was the
universally uh acknowledged and accepted
good Marvel news of this past week
do you mean there was bad Marvel news
well there was questionable Marvel news
in that uh blade which is supposed to be
out next November November 3rd 2023 uh
which was gearing up to begin shooting
this November in Atlanta has lost its
director
who was the director director was a
felon in the Bassam Tariq
um
he uh well you know it's unclear exactly
why he left but the statement from
Marvel is due to continued shifts in our
production schedule the sound is no
longer moving forward as director of
Blade but will remain an executive
producer on the film we appreciate the
sun's talent and all the work he's done
getting blade to where it is
and the sun put out his own statement
saying it's been an honor working with
the wonderful Folks at Marvel we were
able to put together a killer cast and
crew eager to see where the next
director takes the film
what do you think that's all about
um you know it it
it's it's hard to tell it does not seem
entirely like creative differences the
standard uh age-old Hollywood excuse for
people who just didn't get along
um but I think that when John Watts
pulled out of uh Fantastic Four he
similarly said something to the effect
of there's not enough time in the
schedule for me to make the movie that I
think I want to make
and I also need to [ __ ] relax a
little bit after having just delivered
you know no way home
and uh and so I think it was a little
bit of burnout on his end and a little
bit of if we're gonna make a good one we
need more time and I don't think this is
enough time so I'm
I'm pulling out
um so maybe the we've slated these
movies for our giant ongoing initiative
which is the mcu's various phases
um is somewhat unforgiving when it comes
to is the movie ready do I think I can
make the best movie that I can make or
I'll be rushing to production to meet a
release date
it's weird
um
I I you know I'm not the guy that makes
those movies but if I was in that
position
I'd be like yeah [ __ ] I'll do it I
don't care about not having enough time
that's somebody else's problem like they
gotta they they announced a date not me
and somebody does all the visual effects
I'm just glad to choose the actor saying
[ __ ] so
I'm not saying like [ __ ] I could I'm
better than that person but to me it's
just like why would you why would that
be the reason to walk away
I mean it's it's it is all very unclear
it's all very you know Byzantine and
inscrutable and we have no access
whatsoever to the inner workings of it
other than the statements that got
released which are PR statements meant
to pave over publicly whatever the
issues are oh Jesus Christ just
ask already yes I will direct blade if
you need me
um I'm sure they'll pick up somebody
[ __ ] super fast I'm sure or I'm sure
they're going to think that there's some
directors that are like I can't deliver
like there's no way I can make that
schedule you think that's John Watts
that's why he walked away
I mean I think John Watts did say that
he was just a little bit tired I mean
that dude was on the go man [ __ ] like
he finished one in Spider-Man movie
they're like do another he finished that
one do another keep going keep going and
so for him to jump not just off of a
Spider-Man movie the biggest movie of
his career to then jump into a giant
Fantastic Four movie I could see a fella
just saying hey can I just go to Hawaii
for like a year and put my brain back
together
um so I don't know I mean I don't know
any of the internal politics that are
going on in the in the later verse
um who later verse all part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and the blade
at verse
um but yeah so so it's a it is a
developing situation it would
it would not who do you pick for blade
director
I mean if you can empty out the uh the
Hugh Jackman money truck and fill it
back up and send it over to Jordan
Peel's house that would be interesting
why why do you have to fill them a truck
up with money you don't think he'd be
interested in [ __ ] around with blade
um I don't know if if I mean again don't
know Jordan particularly well at all but
he doesn't seem like the kind of cat who
is jumping to do franchise stuff you
know not when in his world the world of
his own creation is perfectly Rosy and
financially rewarding and creatively
fulfilling
um yeah but blade man but blade you know
that would be the reason because it's
blade and it's rehearsal Ali playing
blade but you know it's it's it's
unclear in what shape the script is in
it's unclear in what shape that all the
production designs were it's unclear all
of that stuff is unclear so any director
coming into it is faced with what do we
have what what can we Salvage what works
what doesn't work how long do I have to
get this stuff in shape is it a matter
of weeks because we've got to stick to a
November production date to meet our
November release date
I don't know
I don't know my friends I'm glad that I
don't have to make these decisions the
only decision I have is to be like to
watch it
it's an easy decision because I always
want to watch it
I'm sure they'll [ __ ] figure it out I
mean blade is not going to go undirected
um so I'm sure it's a problem they will
solve relatively quickly but whether or
not it holds to that release date
remains to be seen
goyer wrote the first one right he did
Stephen Norrington directed the first
directed and didn't goyer eventually
wind up directing a blade he directed
the third ring blade Trinity
um with Ryan Reynolds
is that the one where Wesley Snipes
wouldn't talk to the director that's the
one and where you had to apparently
refer to Wesley Snipes only as blade for
the entirety of production respect look
I don't [ __ ] with any actors process if
you think you're blade God bless you're
blade whatever it takes it's exactly
[ __ ] man just don't stab anybody don't
bite anybody
not for realsies but
if you need to be called blade here I am
Mr blade Mr blade
um so yeah we'll see what happens man it
is an open question that probably will
be answered within the next couple of
weeks but it is it is somewhat telling
that
Marvel can uh can undergo
this kind of what looks like internal
chaos is the wrong word because it
doesn't feel like chaos but uncertainty
and then hand wave it away with Ryan
Reynolds and what a huge fact you know
Wolverine movie he's like oh all this
one with the world don't worry about it
we got everything under control he's I
mean think about it they've got news
like loaded in a gun at all times so if
something goes bad they can just be like
and then yeah here's some joy that we
didn't know about because they keep
everything so [ __ ] secret
so for them man they cracked the code
it's like hey man news is about to break
about the blade thing all right uh
launch what put Deadpool in tubes one
and two launch them up plot a solution
one ping only oh nice God nice I want to
marry you that was so good
so nice
um all right what else we got newswise
the last news thing
um is is an interesting story
um for lots of reasons the the sad part
of it
also isn't that said really but James L
Jones at 91 years old
is officially seeding the rights to all
of his Darth Vader voice worked in the
character himself back to Lucasville and
is no longer going to be an active part
in the voicing of Darth Vader
um he hasn't been for a while it was his
voice in Rogue one
um but for all of the Obi-Wan stuff
um his voice was synthesized digitized
it was created in a computer
um by a company called lease feature
which the interesting part of the story
is that Reese speecher is uh it's it's
based in the Ukraine
and they were apparently like running
for their lives when Russia invaded the
Ukraine while having to deliver voice
files
of Darth Vader back for the canogan
production
Jesus talk about [ __ ] pick a lane
yeah like the the story of the surface
of it is oh yeah okay sure I mean I get
it he's he's a much older man and cannot
you know bring that level of of spry
bounce and Menace that he used to be
able to 40 so many years ago
um so okay I understand completely
decision seated back to to lucasfilm and
they will handle it all in a house they
won't bring on a voice double they can
now generate it so you can type in the
words you want Vader to say and he will
say that like kind of cool a little sad
but also kind of cool
um but then the no where the guys were
making it and we're living in the back
of cabs as we're trying to avoid
invasion is uh is surreal the height of
surreality except that it's very much
reality but that these guys who have
figured out how to do this and it's not
it didn't come in the house from
lucasfilm the same way that like the
best deep fakes of Mark Hamill did not
come in Oscar with this film just guys
out in the world who Crack the Code
apparently this film went out and got
them but it just so happened why you
know what like that should be the case I
sit before you in my own comic book
store with a giant guy egregiously
oversized pop of my character because
I'm an outsider artist
somebody not from the system whatsoever
who made a thing and it caught attention
and I became part of the system
stands to reason that people in the
Digital Arts like people who can make
these gorgeous [ __ ] deep fakes
that there are going to be some that
just come out of the Wilds that aren't
working at a studio already and aren't
scooped up by a major but who have put
in the 10 000 hours of practice on their
own and just pop up like putting up a
YouTube video where you're like oh my
God Tom Cruise is like doing flips and
talking weird and [ __ ] and then you
realize that somebody else did it so I
get that man like there's always going
to be Raw Talent out there that's not
like
raw meaning you just gotta shape it
um I should say undiscovered [ __ ]
talent that has refined its skills
um over like a long period of time to
the point where they're as good as if
not better than people that get paid six
figures a year to do that sort of thing
it's very heartening it should it should
keep you heartened kids everybody out
there have you ever watched any of this
[ __ ] and you're like
it's all wrong I'd do it better well
there's a chance you could it's
it's not that anyone can cook it's that
a good cook can come from anywhere yeah
yeah
thank you is that what they did they say
that in the movie or did you just make
the movie better no that's that's that's
legit What uh what's his face
and that's what he goes He because he
had a beef with uh with the [ __ ]
anyone could cook but right final
summation was yeah I realized there
wasn't that anyone could cook it's that
a good cook a good Chef can come from
anywhere
you're gonna make me cry I love that
movie so much
I was thinking about it today
um because I uh critic is best is in the
service of the new
the new needs friends oh oh god oh don't
oh my God you know how good that [ __ ]
movie is it makes a filmmaker's side
with a Critic
and that's how powerful that film is I
remember watching that movie and being
like I just want to give every critic a
hug I want to make some food apparently
that's how you make them like your movie
Brad Bird you infernal genius oh God
that was that was a breathtaking [ __ ]
moment in cinema for me like I I
remember bawling during that whole
sequence and his whole review ugh
uh
yes this thing so you know some people
might feel like kev's too high that has
nothing to do with being a stoner I
don't get high [ __ ] 52 year old man I
get centered it's like coffee
that being said the tears come from a
real place from appreciation of art
place yeah no Brad Bird is brilliant but
I I did have this thought today
um that I then went on Twitter to talk
about somewhat inspired by both The
Incredibles and the most recent Black
Adam trailer which is why why don't why
don't superheroes fly standing straight
up and just moving through the air like
that why do they have to be like that
because Superman did because because at
some point George Reeves had to lay on a
table and they blew a fan in his face
and that's how you made him fly and so
that now is how everybody's supposed to
fly but then you see like the rock
flying I'm like
I can barely kind of look up and so all
they can see is like maybe like 20 of
the field of vision and then you turn to
a sign and then it becomes how do they
what do they see like are there like
super fluids in their eyes to keep their
eyeballs from not drying out or their
eyelids so tight to their faces that the
air doesn't go in and buff it their
brains around like a sneaker and a dryer
like how does light even work
of course it doesn't because it's all
fake but then it's like well you don't
even need yeah I know sorry
apparently I decided to Neil deGrasse
Tyson
um superheroic flight this afternoon
people people I'm sure were happy about
that uh you know absolutely because you
know the internet has a fantastic sense
of humor but most people are like I
never thought about it it's like yeah
because they don't need it's not
generating lift he doesn't have to worry
about control surfaces like Iron Man
Iron Man should be that way because he's
actually got to keep Aloft but Superman
it's a that flight is a power of will it
can go as fast as he can think he can go
I I it's funny you mentioned the like
[ __ ] why are they gonna fly like this
because I'm I got an image in my head of
somebody who's got their arms crossed
Magneto right and he just [ __ ] he
don't do this he just covers on a disc
or whatever the [ __ ] and I bet you
that's probably because Ian McAllen was
like I'm not laying down here boy yeah I
don't do that um but I I yeah if I ever
make a superhero movie who flies
[ __ ] is gonna Magneto across the
screen yeah
why would I be prone
then again if you're upright you're
exposing your heart to attack so maybe
being down is the move
but if you're if you're Superman or Adam
for that matter you're mostly
invulnerable anyway
so
it's just convenience I guess
um this is apropos of nothing but I'm in
the New York Times uh today the physical
New York Times the actual newspaper I
was uh online the article went online
last night I just remembered that record
an actual piece of the newspaper and
it's a story about me and Jason Muse
every once in a while the media writes a
they're still friends story and um this
time it was the New York Times did a
very lovely one
um and uh it's a cool picture of us here
in the store standing in front of
Jesus literally
he just sits over there those who came
in late the Buddy Christ sits over there
and stuff and so that's the Jesus joke I
really hate having to explain my [ __ ]
please get here on time
uh we're done with the news we're done
with news my friend we're done with news
I wanted to talk very briefly about a TV
show that I'm deeply in love with I'm
not sure if you've seen the show
reservation dogs
um I have not but you are not the first
person
to say how much they like the show to me
oh God the point where I'm like I think
I got to give it a roll the first season
is good
um it's it's very specific it's about
four teenagers who you know are are like
the best of friends growing up on a
reservation in Oklahoma
um and it's it's funny and it's serious
and it does that it's it's a little link
later in that way
um the second season is for not
um the second season is just willing to
indulge like these flights of fantasy
um and it's it can be by turns in the
same episode the funniest thing I've
seen in years and the saddest thing I've
ever seen
um that's my kind of [ __ ] Jam right
there oh it is just it's waiting for you
laughter through tears is my favorite
emotion in the movie name the movie I
cannot my friend that's Dolly Parton and
Steel Magnolias my friends
wow that's a deep cut yes
there's like two pigs in a pillow
wrestling
um
um I I stole a line from that movie that
I still use uh to this day a co-opted a
line at one point early in the movie
Julia Roberts is talking to uh it was
Dylan McDermott I think and uh you know
they're not gonna they're about to get
married but they're not going to see
each other until the wedding and she's
like uh he's like I'll see you at the
wedding she goes I'll be the one up
front in the Veil but Josh that was a
really cute line and I co-opted it for
years
um you know I'm always like all right
kids I'll see you in a minute I'll be
the one up front in the white hat nice I
owe [ __ ] not so much Julia Roberts
but Steel Magnolias
I don't know who wrote that space of a
play though right it's not play if I
remember correctly
we should put it on and all male Steel
Magnolias that's what the world is
waiting for yeah like that's what they
used to do in the old days in
Shakespeare they had dudes play ladies
so let's do it [ __ ] we'll do steel
Magnolia's Shakespeare style all the
ladies are men
oh well listen we shouldn't do this but
somebody should do it all drag Steel
Magnolias I agree and I would go watch
that I agree
anyway especially because those parts
are like big you can really play them up
and stuff really go for the drama
because they sure did oh hell yeah Sally
Fields big speech shows the end of that
movie what was the other old ass movie
we were talking about at the beginning
of the show we've lost half the audience
like what is this the [ __ ] Golden
Girls Out The Golden Girls were hyper
and you [ __ ]
Angus Angus and chat said Steel
Magnolias for the all-male cast
oh God that's good [ __ ] that's good
that's a joke that's good for like 12
people out of 100 but still 12 people
matter Mark okay you don't do a show for
the people who don't show up you do the
show for the ones that do
now if 12 people out of 2 000 think of
things funny
1900 change I have to wait
so bad yeah maybe the ratio is not right
but
they'll get theirs one day they get a
joke that other people don't get and
they'll be like ah yes that's the
symptoms has been on the air for 40
years no [ __ ] a few people got very
excited when I did my uh Daniel J Lewis
they were like hey I recognize that
see
not much love for hunt for an October
though
yeah you had all my love for it I wasn't
reading the board then I was reading the
reactions then but I'll tell you this
much ain't nobody going like I love
Steel Magnolias
it's too bad I might be the only one
it's good it's good ass movie
hey
hey it ain't all [ __ ] super Marvel
and bat Potter and star
and whatevs
sometimes it's a little Steel Magnolia
sometimes you gotta watch a movie with
your mother your father I wasn't boy
Under the Stairs Alfred
seriously treated me hopefully you know
what look at mine [ __ ] everybody I own a
movie theater guess what's coming to my
movie theater
no I'm just gonna show an old movie
but uh you know what we could do a
reading oh my God oh my God
me you Ralph Garman [ __ ] Jason Muse
and we pull Scott Moser out of mothballs
and we do an all [ __ ] male reading of
Steel Magnolias Steel Magnolias tell
that
that's [ __ ] up enough to work people
be like I totally buy a ticket to that
how much would you pay to see a show
like that 20. uh five bucks a low price
of forty dollars
uh I would pay more to scrub the
internet from my phone when we do that
because we are not going to be the most
beloved dudes in the world for the
all-male Steel Magnolias but why
we all we have to do is give the money
to charity
there you go you give it to women in
film and [ __ ] there you go or pick uh
some other charity I give up I give all
my residuals to women in film so we can
pick another charity and stuff but as
long as you're giving it to a charity
it's not what do we [ __ ] we're making a
political statement No we're reading a
[ __ ] play and it just happens that
you know that play is full of women but
I would like to read I'd like to [ __ ]
do the Sally Field part man she gets
that she gets a meltdown at the funeral
and [ __ ] no it's okay Selby her daughter
oh
okay I'll do it
DJ Kanto says Puerto Rico is in Mighty
neat there you go
we'll give all the money to [ __ ]
Puerto Rico
oh [ __ ] son Andrea Mastro Batista says
steal dragnolias
oh [ __ ] yes
let me tell you something maybe this
means something maybe you don't but from
the guy who made Clerks
Golf Club
Jeff's kiss as we say around these parts
[ __ ] you
um production
you God see you think big big beeping my
friend
um I'm gonna check out reservation dogs
then man you sold me on the like it's
funny and it'll make you [ __ ] so sad
that's how we got it
half hour of episodes and they're all on
Hulu fun songs
much like andor's episode of life
not fun size 47 minutes
well but it's also like seven minutes of
credits so you're really only getting
like 41.
um shall we get to there are we're done
with the news we're done with the news
here's the there's the news kids only
one more piece of news clerks three the
convenience tour tapping and you can't
stop it go to clerks3.movie for tickets
man we're going to uh coming up to the
California leg man San Francisco and
Sacramento sold out so you're [ __ ]
there but
Los Angeles Anaheim these people don't
like me at all plenty tickets uh the
Balboa theater in San Diego some tickets
left
um go to
clerks3.movie right now
and get your [ __ ] self a ticket if
you're in California if you're not in
California
look go to clerk3.movie and see if we're
coming to your area we sold out another
dollar we sold that sold out another
show it was Dallas so we're adding a
second Dallas show a lot of [ __ ] sold
out shows man it's it's been lovely but
California for some reason a profit's
not ever accepted in his own home
Buccaneer whatever
so Jesus Jesus
can't see him he said he's hiding he's
shy
Fred Armisen has Prince as Jesus he's uh
no the problem is Jane the giant James
on Bob Pops at night when the store
closes down they bully Jesus
because he's the prince of peace and
they are the [ __ ] you know
middle-aged Mischief Makers I don't have
a name for him but you know [ __ ]
there's a never-ending battle they fight
all night long that'd be fine but very
nice religious thing it ain't like a
Jesus thing it's just like hey long hair
and he can't get it because they both
have long hair
um battle for dominance
um all right shall we get into the
reviews let's do it
uh here's the review clerks three is an
amazing movie come see it with me on the
convenience store clerks3.movie
it's great all right that's been a show
good night everybody
this and or picture
television show indeed by Tony Gilroy
correct me if I'm wrong
this is the same Tony Gilroy who
didn't he didn't he do Michael Clayton
he did indeed okay number one I trust
this man to do anything because Michael
Clayton is one of the greatest films
ever made
that being said
this [ __ ] show is dope I this was the
[ __ ] show that I had no interest in
whatsoever
I'm like Andor he dies
and this is the first show that I really
feel like kind of expands the Star Wars
universe
like we're not on tattooing we're not
necessarily dealing with a Skywalker
story yes the Empire is this nebulous
Gathering storm
but here in the outskirts you know uh
the Rebellion slowly begins
had no idea I would like it as much as I
do and it's doing things no other Star
Wars things has done for example
casual overnight sex how about that yeah
they just she came to his house and they
[ __ ] and the next morning they showed
her pulling her pants up Mark
that's dirty nobody's ever done that in
Star Wars
bam nobody ever pulled their pants
here's an expert right here they also
uh your friend Carrie Fisher famously
said there's no underwear in space but
that woman very clearly is wearing
multiple underwear on top and bottom I
thought of her when I saw that as well I
was like there's underwear right there
um the people are saying spoilers this
is I'll put up a spoiler thing
episode two like what did they put up a
bunch of episodes at once or what they
put up the first three at once and then
episode four dropped this is two weeks
old yeah put up the spoilers thing I
mean what to say that people have sex in
a Star Wars thing that ain't no spoiler
that's that's a rejoicer you should be
doing dance You Should Be Dancing like
that scene in the one Matrix that nobody
likes where everyone's like
it's
time to get down I was on a plane and
somebody chose to watch that and so they
were next to me and so I was casually
watching the dance scene and even with
the sound not on I'm like this is an
easy lift you could have cut that whole
thing but to be fair the machovskis are
such brilliant filmmakers I'm sure
they've watched my body of work and said
you can cut all of it it all blows I
will say that there is if you if you
really want it on the YouTubes there's
an hour-long Zion dance rave mix so
somebody just looped the footage just
looped it over and over and over again
here I was just [ __ ] on it [ __ ]
in the mouth of Zion and the dance party
what you just sold me I'm buying because
I can totally see putting that on going
to sleep to that yeah going to sleep
going what were they thinking it's also
the only part of Matrix two that anybody
remembers like 25 years later
everybody's like what happened in Matrix
two I don't know but that the dance rave
sex thing it's the lightning rod scene
it's the thing that grabs all the
[ __ ] energy because people like did
you see how long they danced in them
movie
um all right let's talk Andrew and JC uh
Batman you should stick around for this
all right yeah I have ideas I have
thoughts I'm sure I have thoughts let me
tell you I have no notes whatsoever I
thought this show was incredibly adult
and grown up like
it was the first time I've watched a
Star Wars thing and felt oh this isn't
for kids and not because it's like oh
it's too violent it's just this is
[ __ ] this is for adults this [ __ ]
show
grown-ups treating Star Wars in the
grown-up fashion I felt like when I
watched this it's like Espionage like a
thriller man and I love that [ __ ] uh
International it was a lot of different
accents this time
oh yeah somebody in chat just pointed
out in the first episode and or the show
starts with him in a brothel
yeah he's in a [ __ ] yes I was gonna
say a whorehouse but I guess we
shouldn't say it but yes he's in a
brothel you said it right the first time
um yeah and then he [ __ ] you know
gets he acts well are we were we
spoilers yeah
he when he [ __ ] accidentally kills a
dude man it's like that's that just felt
real I've never done that but it felt
like oh [ __ ] this is like a grown-up
show you could watch this on like you
know this is this is like a Dick Wolf
show if you take it out of space I mean
he accidentally kills a dude and then
very much on purpose kills another dude
but we met that and door before like we
saw Andor kill a [ __ ] at the
beginning of Rogue one just kind of like
coldly like I gotta do what I gotta do
so that scene
like that part was like oh that's that's
how he got to be that guy but the
[ __ ] dude that he accidentally kills
which I think he [ __ ] accidentally
killed him by bashing his
head into his nose right like because
that dude grabbed him and he hit this
[ __ ] and then you know he was fighting
the other guy I don't know if he ever
re-engaged with the other guy but I the
way I took it was him head-button him
did the thing that we always talked
about when we were in [ __ ] kids in
school that if somebody was like cha and
did this at the right angle the BR the
bone goes into the brain and you die
instantly
that's what I got out of all that you
guys I mean it's a design flaw to be
sure in the human body but yeah I think
that's what we're supposed to take
and it's and I think it's it might be
less you die instantly but more you
drown in your own blood
is what actually ends up happening
um either way that's right you drown in
your own I think it's because all the
blood that's you know like up in here is
all [ __ ] blood vessels from your
brain is a pretty decent uh receptacle
for it goes down into your throat into
your lungs
the uh remember when Batman fought the
mutant leader he [ __ ] busted this and
[ __ ] like that yeah and then in jail he
was just like you got kids
[Laughter]
Batman don't shift all right back to
Andor this show don't shiv at all
um honestly duly impressed I've only
watched the two episodes
um but um
you know
this is in the criticism right raising
one to lower the others uh I loved
Obi-Wan but you know that had elements
of there was a child character and so it
felt like it was still geared toward
kids family this just felt like they
were like take the kids out of the room
and not because it's like too gross or
too [ __ ] you know uh violent just
because you're dealing with like they're
treating this [ __ ] seriously like if you
know if you took it out of space and put
it on Earth
felt like like a crime procedural it
felt like you know
I don't know it's it's this story of
radicalization right it's about you know
how how a person
goes from living their life thinking
about themselves to thinking about more
than that you know and so like even to
your point like yeah Obi-Wan has a kid
in it this the whole first three
episodes of this show
have a whole storyline about young
Cassian before he's and or just Casa as
a kid on Canary and I love it because we
don't have any access to that language
it's not even subtitles
in the subtitles they don't even tell us
they just give us a idea like and you
can do it that's strong storytelling I
remember I was watching that going like
excellent [ __ ] choice I put on
exactly what's happening I put on the
closed caption I'm like should this be
subtitle I rewound it and tried to watch
it and I was like oh no they're just
gonna roll with this
yeah
you know and so you know everything
about that little like youth Society we
don't know where they came from we know
where their parents are but we get the
relationships between between everybody
we get that they're curious about this
this Imperial craft that went down we
get the tentative nature and we get the
the loss at having you know gasolineated
at some point it loses
sister best friend unclear but all of
that emotion happens all that story
plays in a way that is still more mature
than every flashback we got on the Boba
Fett
like it's actually story that's relevant
to why does this person decide to join
the rebels like why what what what about
him when he was young
like laid the fuse that's still in
Skarsgard later on is going to light you
know what's what about his life who is
he portraying Stone Skarsgard he's new
um yeah right it's nobody he's we've
never seen because I was when he popped
up I was like oh [ __ ] and then I was
like wait he's never been in a store he
looks similar to like one of the
generals
that you see in Rogue one but I don't
think it's
that I don't think they're the same
person I also find the procedural with
the young Imperial or the I mean I am
all Imperials or not they're corporate
the sector Authority right so the the
guy the young kid who's investigating
the [ __ ] murders and [ __ ] who's got
the the kind of dog whistling best buddy
who's like everybody clap and [ __ ] like
that
um that I thought even that story was
really [ __ ] interesting and grown up
and not of a Star Wars thing at all no
like every every scene is about the
people in that scene and every one of
those scenes is written in an incredibly
interesting sort of way and it starts in
one place and it ends another place
every scene has a purpose and yeah I
mean the lieutenant Gorman of the
corporate security like who wants to do
everything by the book who doesn't want
to give up on anything who who
disregards the the the orders from his
his higher-ups to investigate the murder
of these two shlubs on this on this you
know board planet or whatever
like it all starts to track it all makes
sense and you all kind of understand
what everybody and every scene is
looking for like I know what Endor wants
you know I know what his best friend
wants I know like he just wants I want
to make enough money to get the hell off
of this thing I got this box that seems
to belong to the Empire
I just gotta sell it give me enough
credits I just I just and I want to find
my sister like all of those wants and
needs are super [ __ ] clear you know
and then the first three episodes feel
very much like act one of this story
like then by episode four you're
launching into what feels like the
beginning of of cassian's career as an
operative for the for the rep for the
Rebellion but even those first three
stories are just like here's here's what
his life is here's what his world is and
here's what he wants
um you know and every time people who
feel like they're from the Empire start
to talk it's like you're in Michael clay
it's like you're in some boardroom it's
like you're in some some like music it's
super short people truly the banality of
evil which is something that they don't
do in Star Wars in Star Wars It's the
dramatic evil it's the obviousness of
evil it's the arch evil it's we're gonna
blow up a [ __ ] Planet evil this is
the banality of evil just the paperwork
the [ __ ] like you know like well
let's just roll you know this is this
wasn't a murder this was a fight
and [ __ ] like the tiny Bureau
bureaucratic [ __ ] nooks and crannies
that allows
eventual evil to thrive yeah there's a
great speech in episode four
um by uh you know I I don't even know
what that character is I'm sure JC has a
better read on it but it's very much
these are the Imperial officers who are
tasked with overseeing this particular
quadrant of the Empire it's uh it's in
Imperial Security Bureau it's ISB it's
like their CIA I guess would be the
equivalent yeah and it gives us great
speech about how we're not we're not
cops we're not policemen we're doctors
we're surgeons and what we do is we
diagnose the problems in the Empire and
we figure out is there a germ that's out
of places there are womb that's infected
is there a bone that's broken and we go
in and we fix it and we eradicate the
parts that's infecting it we cleanse the
wound and then we push on through like
the the just that finality of evil the
the disaffection of it that we're
removing the humanity from the job of
impressing our will upon a Galaxy
it's chilling but it's so well done
the um the thing that I think
I love so much about Andor
uh that has been missing in almost
everything since the original Star Wars
is that it makes me believe that this is
happening at some other Galaxy right now
like when I first saw Star Wars you know
it was a long a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away it opens up
basically telling you oh this is real
and there's so much
like backwards referential fan service
and everything since
that this especially the first three
episodes where you don't see a
stormtrooper it was like the first time
I've watched Star Wars in
30 years where I was like oh this this
could be happening like Mark and I
talked a couple episodes back about like
what is
what makes a star war is it the
mysticism is it the um is it Jedi is it
what is it and I think that's what it is
for me it's like oh I believe that this
could be happening so on some other
planet right now and Andor did that for
me it made me believe as an adult that
like oh yeah these people are out there
fighting this war somewhere
up in the Stars
um I really
I loved it
um yeah like I don't need there to be
Jedi I mean and when we talked about
that JC for me
it was it was the sound of it like Star
Wars is a is an audio experience for me
which is laser sound like the lasers
when they're Star Wars like when you do
eventually begin to hear Tie fighters
you know it's like oh yeah there it is
like it's the the soundscape of it and
there's this amazing [ __ ] scene in
episode three that the tension builds
entirely based on sound and it's Ambient
sound in the show
um but it yeah it has it has the feel of
yeah it's Star Wars but I don't expect
ever to see a Jedi to the point when you
see like still in scars are carrying a
thing that looks like it could be a
lightsaber like please don't be a
lifesaver like I don't want that to
people
yeah I um
I also loved it just kind of drops you
in here
like against the original Star Wars just
kind of drops you in and you have to
figure out what a moisture farmer does
and what Stormtroopers like you have to
kind of like catch up to it
um and I felt like this did that same
thing it didn't explain to you what was
happening they didn't subtitle the
foreign languages like you got dropped
into the middle of something that was
happening and then by the end of the
first episode you'd kind of caught up to
what what's going on
uh which I also really
like worked for me really well
yeah like I just I and it feels big it
feels huge in a way that Star Wars on TV
has not felt I don't feel the volume on
this show the way I felt
um you know Mandalorian even though it's
done incredibly well or Boba Fett where
it doesn't feel like it was done that
well at all or Obi-Wan Kenobi where it
looked like they were in a fishbowl you
know what like
good oh it's just gonna say you know
what a lot of that is
this show has hundreds of insert shots
meaning I feel like the other Star Wars
TV shows are told in you know medium
close-ups and wides it's like shooting
coverage and this has tons of insert
shots of like the person pushing the
button and the
the kids walking over a log yeah just
like little things like pushed in on it
and I was like well something's gonna
happen and it was just an insert shot
yeah
I mean there's a scene in episode three
of a of a speeder going across what
looks like rice paddies
and it's just it's this wide shot and
you're just seeing a thing that I've
never seen before in Star Wars and then
it looks like a planet I've never been
to
and it's doing and it's just it's
beautiful and it's wide and the vistas
are real and I never got that feeling
from Kenobi you know I I there's whole
planets we get to and start to feel a
bit like
you know um the the Star Wars Jedi
what's what's the most recent game
falling order where you're just like
with guys who are salvaging old Imperial
or old spacecraft
and it just looks like a junkyard like a
huge junkyard it's a it's a ship
graveyard and these giant machines are
swinging in and I saw one ship I was
like well I bet you that's that's like
God cast this [ __ ] that's what he was
out at the beginning of falling order
um like the Easter eggs aren't there
they mentioned scarif in in I think in
episode four
um they also uh in episode four they
have uh
starkillers armor costume from the Force
Unleashed game against the wall and
stuff yeah
you know and then episode four spoilers
again we meet Senator Monmouth
um sort of at the at the beginning or
the beginning of her disillusionment
with the Empire and just the weird
little domestic drama that she has with
her shitty husband
um and it just it makes it all feel so
much more real it makes it all feel so
much more believable that like yeah not
only does she want to do her part to try
and start a rebellion but she wants to
get out of this shitty [ __ ] marriage
and how do you personify those two how
do you personify the awfulness of Life
on Coruscant how better to do that by
here's the schmuck that I'm having to
marry who's thoroughly and totally
inconsiderate to everything that I care
about
she was the Empire she was also awesome
in as uh the same actress who was in
Revenge of the Sith who got six words of
dialogue maybe and then was brought back
in Rogue one who got like 12 words of
dialogue like she really
got to act in this and be like like
you know show off what she could
actually do which I thought was kind of
cool
yeah and like they're still in Skarsgard
is bringing the [ __ ] high heat like
there's nobody on this show
that's that's half stepping in any way
um it's just like yeah and I know that
there's some people like I've seen a bit
online are people who didn't know what
to expect but don't quite like what
they're getting
um that it feels slow that it feels a
little monotonous
um I don't know I'm just I'm eating up
every one of these scenes with all these
characters and I get that it's building
towards something
um and yes that something is as Tony
giveaway had said in three years Rogue
one is we're building to
um and so the end of this series will be
the beginning of Rogue one but I'm I
don't know man I'm on board for the ride
I think this is the best Star Wars we've
had since we've had Star Wars on TV
um with the exception of certain
episodes of Mandalorian which I do love
to death
um but as a whole so far these four
episodes are just it crazy good it just
felt like like the Mandalorian to me
which I love like getting to see Luke
Skywalker come back was like
the only thing I don't ever have to
watch Star Wars again after getting that
but it felt very much like going to your
childhood home and having your mom cook
your favorite meal that you haven't had
because you've been away at college and
like there's just something very like
warm and comforting about it and or
feels like
like something you've never tasted
before but is still something that you
love that fits in your palette like it's
so it feels so new and different but
like
it still makes sense like the first time
like
you know you're eating a new candy or
something you're like oh my God I didn't
know this existed but I love candy
mm-hmm
uh may I jump in yes sir uh Chad is
accusing me of being baked and that's
why I'm quiet uh not the case at all
kids my mom uh lives in Florida and I
don't know if people have been paying
attention to the news but in the real
world outside of the Andor Universe kids
um there's a hurricane bearing down on
Florida so I keep checking in
with my mom to make sure that she's okay
she's holding up fine she's more Inland
so they're okay but
I keep hearing from people who are like
near Orlando and I'm like well how come
I'm not hearing from Mom
um so some people thought I was big some
people thought I was trying to avoid
spoilers
um I was able to avoid spoilers uh
because I was texting with Mom but uh
everything
good good
um all right so uh the um the uh are we
done with Andor sucking into his dick
we've uh yeah now Diego Luna has been in
my mouth for a while and I think I'm
ready to spit him out he's absolutely
wonderful uh spoilers uh do they get are
we ever gonna see uh the Alan Tudyk
robot
um
Maybe
uh I'll take it I'll say if you don't
see him by episode four
um whether or not we eventually get
there Oh I thought you were trying not
to spoil it for me no I mean how do you
not like this would be a great time for
them to [ __ ] meet right
um my other thing is uh this is
unrelated to Andor but have you been
following this [ __ ] werewolf By Night
stuff
they showed it at Fantastic Fest in
Austin the whole episode
and uh people [ __ ] loved it loved it
yeah like
did you see the trailer somebody said
there's a trailer yeah no the trailer
dropped um and d23 and they put it up
online and it's directed by [ __ ]
Michael giacchino
he's a he's a composer
yeah a great composer an amazing
composer but you don't see me trying to
compose do you
hey Mike
uh that's how awesome I love when people
like you know [ __ ] step out of their
comfort zone once an artist always an
artist man if you can [ __ ] compose
the scores that he does
that's directing notes what's the
difference in [ __ ] directing a thing
and apparently he had a passion for it
because it bleeds through in the black
and white yeah have you heard that this
man thing pops up in it
yeah no I think he's in the trailer
I gotta watch this trailer I'm sorry
I've had my head up my ass with clerks
three
the convenience tour man uh you can come
see it come see clerks three with me on
the road in a city near you tickets at
clerks3 dot movie uh yeah I was shocked
that [ __ ] like they threw a little
man thing in there yeah I think they're
just unloaded like all of the joyous
Marvel horror stuff like just let's
let's get into it
honestly it's a great time to be alive
man absolutely so glad I lived through
that heart attack I mean not the least
of which I got to make like Jason Bob
reboot and clerks three uh clerks three
dot movie but um I also get to see show
put [ __ ] man thing in a black and
white werewolf By Night [ __ ]
like Disney plush it's crazy we're crazy
you know I know the internet is
engineered for people to complain but
like
who can complain at such a time of
bounty like this great time to be alive
indeed are you uh are you at all caught
up yeah don't do it don't do it
oh no what up on what
um posted the dragon and or Lord of the
Ring rings of power I'm not a Rings guy
so I won't engage with that I'm sure
they did a great job but I I don't I
didn't I didn't go for the Rings movies
I don't think I'm gonna go for Rings Tv
show
uh and that's you know I'm again
everything I've seen I was like oh my
God it looks magnificent but I'm not a
Tolkien guy
um and then what was the other thing
House of the Dragon
I have not gone back to the house of the
Dragon yet I should because
uh I talked about today on my post my
Instagram post
um we got a bunch of guests I know I saw
for a [ __ ] smodcast Castle Cinemas I
was on a plane the other day I had time
so I was like I'm just gonna start
texting everyone in my Rolodex and see
if they want to come play
and so I was texting with uh Joe Russo
and what a delight he was and he was
just like oh my God we're in Atlanta
shooting a movie we could fly into
Newark like what day we picked a day and
he was like done and done I said what do
you want to show he's like let's show
them what they want to see
really and he's like let's show both I'm
like back to back he's like yeah man my
brother will come down and talk so
Extinction one and two exactly both
remains she uh so there's that coming up
George RR Martin is going to come
because he's got a uh House of the
Dragons book I think coming out uh art
book or something so Jersey Boys
originally from [ __ ] Bayonne and what
a fanboy so he's going to come to the
theater I think that's in early November
the russos are in early December
um
and uh you know he's entertaining as
[ __ ] so George you know I was like oh we
could show a house of dragons he's like
you'll have to pay HBO and I was like
they got enough of my money so we don't
I don't think we'll be showing anything
we're just showing you [ __ ]
Grim himself man the man show an episode
of the Beauty and the Beast that he
wrote
is that right did he work on that show
back in the day yeah the Ron permanent
Hamilton show wow he's been around for a
red hot minute yeah
um then uh who else I reach out to Zack
Snyder
and uh I text him I was exist still you
and he goes it's still me and uh I said
hey man I bought a movie theater
can you come to a screening and he was
like is it near Red Bank and I was like
how the [ __ ] do you know Red Bank New
Jersey
um and it is because of his wife Deb
she's like she she spent a lot of time
there but he's also a [ __ ] Jersey kid
as well
um he spent some time here so
uh you know he I was like uh what do you
want to show and he's like well there's
that one movie I made that has never
been shown in the theater and I was like
We'll show every minute of it
[ __ ] so he's coming to do it
[ __ ] q a
um
uh Jason Reitman
uh is talking about coming before he
goes off to and do his next movie
um
and uh who else
James guy reached out to James Gunn and
I was like hey man I bought a movie
theater do you want to come show
something to a q a and he goes oh my God
that sounds fun I would love to if you
don't hear from me in the next 10
minutes it's only because I'm getting
married today oh no I I you know I I'll
hook up with him later on I didn't want
to get in the way of the nuptials but um
yeah man [ __ ] we're bringing we're
bringing the Thunder to smodcast Castle
Cinemas man
I know it I'm excited Good Times me and
Mark are going to be doing when are we
talking about doing fat man beyond uh
I'm not sure I mean we talked about
December a little bit but it may end up
being the new issue of New Year's stuff
it could be in the New Year marks um and
do a signing at the stash for Adora and
his other books and uh at night we'll do
a fat man beyond its podcast we might
even be able to bring this short a
splinter
and show it on the big screen yeah oh
oh Jeff's kiss my friend I'd buy a
ticket to that show and I own the
[ __ ] Twitter
let me tell you something about owning a
movie theater and living above it Mark
you can go downstairs and watch anything
you want
in the middle of night I can go
downstairs like I was talking to the
kids Josh and Liv and we were talking
about Drugstore Cowboy they never saw it
I was like how do you not know if it's
[ __ ] early Gus found son and they
didn't know my own private Idaho either
so I was like oh my God if you guys are
gonna watch those movies I'll watch them
with you and [ __ ] and then I was like
wait a second we're all gonna be in
Jersey next weekend let's [ __ ] just
put them up on one of the [ __ ] movie
theater screens watch them in a movie
theater because movie theater is All
Digital now we don't have 35 millimeter
film we're not cool like that we're just
digital like everything else but that
means that you could [ __ ] plug your
laptop in [ __ ] watch anything I can
put PornHub up on the movie screen and
jerk off alone in an empty movie theater
uh well the leak Blower's not gonna work
[Laughter]
just spreads it out God forbid somebody
trips into it
um okay
let's talk about
somebody said get wild Samurai goes get
Dolly's partner stop by that'd be a
dream oh nine to five and do a dog show
nine to five and have her come talk or I
would show Best Little Whorehouse in
Texas
or Steel Magnolias
foreign
that's why you never say nothing about
the [ __ ] Mohawk because he's a good
boy
good ideas
that's brilliant sir well done yes a
Steel Magnolia is [ __ ] screening
with dolly
and Daryl Hannah and Julia Roberts see
how many you could pull together at that
point
I'll get them all together gather all
the steel Magnum
you'd have to stream that then if you
got a Steel Magnolias like 30-year
reunion how amazing yeah particularly
for this the fat man beyond audience is
like talking about this old ass movie
it was a fathom events
um JC when we do fat man beyond from New
Jersey you can Banff in on the big
screen behind us
that'd be awesome because it'll be the
same it'll be the same setup but then
[ __ ] periodically you'll Banff it
it'll be the opposite setup though
because like you guys would be hosting
and then I'd be like the virtual guy
well it was no because you'll still
be just this oh right because we'll
still be streaming yeah so you'll still
be in charge
and but it's just when you pop up you'll
pop up on the Move screen because we'll
be there live and behind us it'll be
projected on the giant screen
I bought a movie theater at the right
time in life Mark like I couldn't have
appreciated this when I was a younger
man I was too ambitious but now you ask
the critics I have no ambition
whatsoever I just made Clark's [ __ ]
three so that means I got a lot of free
[ __ ] time to like program a movie
theater and [ __ ] here's an event that I
can't wait to do so you we all know Josh
Roush Dr Josh Roush uh Josh has made all
the documentaries for the last few
movies I've made so he did the Jay and
Silent Bob reboot uh Magnum dopas
um he did one for clerks three he did
one for for Tusk he's making this
documentary about Michael Parks he's
been working on for three years and
stuff still waiting for Quentin
Tarantino to do his interview and uh he
just finished his first feature film
wrong reasons so I say to Josh I was
like we're gonna do a
feat to you with a week-long screening
series of all your movies at smodcast
Castle and then it finishes up with
wrong reasons and then presumably he
goes out on tour with this movie now
the artist's name again is Josh Rausch
what would you call that film series
mark
oh
see my smugness I I know I I don't have
it I don't have it what do you call it
Rao shaman
thank you
thank you nice thank you
some shit's worth doing just because the
marketing Hook is so [ __ ] sharp
I have one for you fire away I would
like to program a week
at the smog Castle Theater
the second week of March
and we call it the Ides of Mark
what do you program
uh I don't know but was that fun I mean
I love it oh my God guest programmer and
you just hey I got an apartment above
the place you can [ __ ] stay with me
yes if you've ever wanted to watch
PornHub on the Giants
that's a good idea but that's the thing
see [ __ ] like that it ain't just funny
that's doable it's doable like why
wouldn't we do it man who would like
think about it the audience we have on
this show people [ __ ] show up for the
Ides of Mark
especially if we're showing Flash Gordon
midnight run bro you know we're [ __ ]
showing here one day
well of course dude I was going for uh
Streets of Fire
see look
Bizarro the Gay Blade
sing along
one bad stand just three songs now we
don't do that one we do
we do nowhere fast we do uh tonight is
what it means to be young and we do I
could dream about you we just fast
forward through a lot of the movie so
it's the 45 minute that Street's about
oh man here's the dream all right if you
could have a Streets of Fire screening
with Diane Lane right
maybe do a double feature a [ __ ]
Streets of Fire and ladies and gentlemen
there's some fabulous stains okay
or singer twice yes Willem Dafoe
that's that's not me clapping that's me
giving you all my money for that really
good idea
which then goes back into your pocket
because you own the movie
can I tell you a very funny story about
this evening right before I got here so
it's not really a story and it's not
very funny but it's kind of cute I'll
take it so I bought a movie theater for
those who came in late
um my whole uh not my hometown because
that's Highlands but the next town over
is Atlantic Highlands but technically
this is my hometown movie theater
because Highlands never had a movie
theater while I was alive so Atlantic
Highlands uh the Atlantic Twin Cinema
which became the Atlantic movie house
um at five screens uh I bought it with a
bunch of friends of mine Ernie O'Donnell
uh Ashley uh uh Jeff Swanton Ashley
dejorno
I I was I was I always want to say
Ashley Lilo props because that's her
business and [ __ ]
um
so
I was at the business tonight because we
closed and we officially own it and I
got a key somewhere here for [ __ ] the
apartment upstairs and [ __ ]
so um I'm just hanging out in the movie
theater and and whatnot and uh
um I was chit chatting with Ernie and I
saw the people in the lobby bought
tickets come in and they go to the
concession stand
and you know my movie Clerks 3 is
playing in the main theater
I know people yeah
um and
the people that came in and bought some
you know bought tickets and bought
snacks they head toward my movie theater
then they bank right and they go to a
different movie they go see the woman
King
and I'm like
this is gonna be weird owning the
theater when you're showing your own
movie there because like it's win-win
either way right they go to see clerks
they go to see the woman King I'm making
the money but the ego
on the filmmaker Kevin Smith as he
watched them head off to the woman King
and I was just like
maybe I should go upsell them on clerks
three
I gotta hey everybody there's a really
great picture happening over here hey
woman King is great and he's but there's
a boy prince in there
it's me
let's see here's an update uh from my
mom yeah hey I just watched a couple
alligators float down the middle of my
street
the wind's gone like it's 50 miles per
hour I think by now I have
to not thank your father for never
teaching me how to swim
I'll use my purple asthma vest as a life
preserver ha ha you are not the only one
you're not the only funny one
isn't that cute that's my mother
no we're dry inside with rain outside
good thing I got my roof fixed thanks
tiger
and I low-key just told you that I fixed
my mom's roof nice job thank you well
a boy loves his mother mark
we uh we have some late breaking sad
news Kevin
what rapper Coolio died today at age 59.
how
um let's see
JC yes question
anyway back to you mark JC is suggesting
we skip q a tonight because he has a
yeah at the bar he's got the trivia
thing so I said yeah absolutely oh my
God Cardiac Arrest he just had a
flat-out heart attack and died yeah
yeah
I mean look as a guy who [ __ ] lived
through a heart thing that breaks mine
like [ __ ]
yeah I mean Julio
I went Africa yeah not uh not
particularly germane to nerd [ __ ] but
for guys who grew up listening to rap in
the 80s and 90s and also Dangerous Minds
video with Michelle Pfeiffer who played
Catwoman in Batman Returns so you found
it
um that's oh my God too young 59 is too
young to [ __ ] die of a heart attack
absolutely God damn it
well
I hope he enjoyed his his life I hope he
had the time of his life
I hope so too seemed like you did
yeah it doesn't seem like it was a bad
one but I also hadn't been following him
too closely for the last few years so
who knows Evan Fowler pointed out rapper
Coolio star of Affleck Daredevil deleted
scenes remember he was in Daredevil
that's right
that's right
um
Batman and Robin
was he
he was he was part of the uh like the
the bike Punk gang that uh oh you're
right
yeah the neon punks neon bugs
wow
we're getting old Mark the r d my friend
I had no idea he was older than me I
thought I was older than him I mean you
know but you're not old if you buy
yourself a movie theater
Forever Young
once sang to us
um yeah
yeah man well if that's the [ __ ]
keep maybe that's like the Dorian Gray
effect you buy a movie theater
and the old version of you stays in the
movie theater
and young you gets to go out into the
world like Dorian Gray listen I'm not
just saying that you invented like the
Majestic 2 or some [ __ ] but
there's a movie there about the guy
who's lived his whole life
did uh you know sort of determined by
defined by the movies that he loves and
so there's a part of him that remains in
the in the movie house one goes out into
the world and lives a life but can't
ever really live a life that he enjoys
until he can synthesize those two hats
of himself shut the [ __ ] up this is good
don't give it away that's good
God you do this all the time why can't
you just be like I'm gonna put me on
mute and then text me and I'll be like
don't [ __ ] at you that's a legit good
script
you're always giving it away for free
I'm sorry I'm I'm a river to my people
why are they ever going to buy the cow
Mark when they can get the [ __ ] milk
for free
Ryan Lynch my friend Brian Lynch who
wrote uh like the you know the um
uh what are those characters from The
Minion verse right minions yeah he wrote
the Minions movies and stuff he worked
for that company illumination
elimination for years and stuff
he [ __ ] texted me yesterday
with a one-line description of like what
I was like that is a [ __ ] brilliant
comedy may I please direct it it was so
good I'll tell you about it later on I
ain't gonna spoil it but I I was about
to go on stage he's like ask the
audience what they think and I was like
[ __ ] no I'm not telling anybody that
idea it's [ __ ] legit wonderful man
um yeah so you're you guys are both the
same you're trying to give it out and
[ __ ] trying to just throw on your little
[ __ ] everywhere stop it thank you
this idea [ __ ] come have some yeah all
that idea [ __ ] it's just throwing it
around don't don't let everyone touch
your idea [ __ ]
a bunch of people right now I was like
did it have to be idea [ __ ] what about
idea dick because we all know that we
the big idea is to have the dick touched
sure
indeed yes it's expectation of the Big
Ideas that's what conflicts with
ambition
with like I could get a thing done
you're like oh I just want someone to
look at it
laughs
speaking of which staff man where the
[ __ ] are you
Grant
um tell them a pump uh pimp your bar
tell them why uh what they why they
can't have q a so maybe
I yeah if you want a q a you can come
talk to me in person I'll answer your
questions
um because I know that's what everybody
in chat is hoping for uh don't get cute
people think you're famous bro I hear
from people all the time when I'm on the
road and they're like I love you Mark
and Banff man they include you
I'm like uh you're like Ralph Garmin
when he was on K-Rock with Kevin and
Bean his name was never in the title but
he was with the guy that everyone tuned
in for the um yeah I'm like the little
Robin after in Batman animated series
when like Robin because when Dick
Grayson becomes Nightwing and I'm like
the little guy
um I'm uh I have started hosting and
writing nerd trivia uh at scum and
villainy every Wednesday
so I harvest geek news all week and uh
and we talk we I quiz you on nerdy stuff
it's basically like this show but you
have to answer all the questions
um
I love trivia eight o'clock eight
o'clock at uh the scum and villainy
cantina yes yes and if you win if you
score the best we give you a sixty
dollar bar tab
for the next time you come in
so if you're really good at trivia you
don't ever pay to eat or drink at the
bar
that's nice so get all that money when
you come and see me and Malcolm do a
black man beyond that's coming villainy
on October 11th at 8 00 p.m tickets on
sale at eventbrite.com or up on my uh my
Twitter or on the Instagram here it is I
got an event to sell other than that
other than clerks three of course the
convenience tour continues to roll
across the country uh October 8th I'm
gonna be back here in Jersey and uh
doing Hollywood Babylon at uh at the
smog Castle Cinemas the very first uh
Jersey Babylon if you will Ralph's
coming out and that's at nine o'clock
October 8th tickets at
atlanticmoviehouse.com it's gonna change
soon
um and then at 11 o'clock we're showing
Tusk [ __ ] I'm gonna do a q a afterwards
like a late night show
so come this mod Castle the Fun's just
getting started wait until we do clerks
open all night that's when we start
watching clerks at midnight then we
watch clerks too after that we watch
clerk three after that and then at five
six in the morning we eat a catered
breakfast from Quick Stop groceries
[ __ ] nice see I [ __ ] when first you
make the movies
then
you make
the movie's fun
yeah I'm Workshop that's first draft
it'll be better can I get a pork roll
egg and cheese on a sesame Bagel bro
you're not you're not joking around
we're gonna be doing grilled cheese
because I went to the Rio theater and
then the Corinne who owns a place is
like get a liquor license she's like I
would never own a movie theater without
a liquor license she's like because
[ __ ] who comes to movies adults and
they love to drink and then she said get
two panini makers and sell grilled
cheese I was like seriously she goes
everybody loves grilled cheese we sell
thousand two thousand bucks of grilled
cheese a night
days and if you own a movie theater
here's the dirty secret you're in the
food service industry that's it you know
movie business takes all the money and
[ __ ] Studios take all the money so I'm
gonna have to grill [ __ ] cheese
Connor who works at the theater tonight
I was sitting around talking with the
kids I was I was confabbing with the
kids I was tick-tocking with the kids
mark
Connor he said uh what about Pop-Tarts I
was like what the [ __ ] about Pop-Tarts
goddamn right because if you went to the
movie theater and somebody was like
would you like a strawberry Pop-Tart how
would you say [ __ ] no and it's not
even some off-brand like toaster tart
it's like legit Pop-Tart
you'd pay five bucks for that Pop-Tart
if it was heated and [ __ ] and guess what
I'll uh I'll throw you a freebie that we
used to do at scum and villain that
people loved you know those uncrustable
peanut butter and jelly sandwich
deep fry them
well I don't have a deep fryer oh well
get a deep fryer that's a whole other
thing that's a kitchen but can I put it
on crustable in a panini grill yeah you
could probably do that just heat it up
heat up nice and nice get a little
butter spray here's the thing an
uncrustable you buy a box of them per
unit maybe about 88 cents
I heat it up for you on a panini grill
and I give it back to you
yeah hey there you go there's a boy
who's thinking right there I like the
way you think businessman
tips from you I'll uh I'll also say if
you do get a liquor license I know of I
mean I know you have movies but I do
know of a bar that survived a pandemic
that is relatively successful that
could use an East Coast location
done and done oh my God are you kidding
me oh look I'll start uh bad-mouthing
some bars in town hoping one goes out we
can pick it up
[Laughter]
I'm gonna go in there like Eckhart and
I'm like I'm gonna ruin you already with
this reputation I'm talking about low it
ain't my voice and then somebody's like
that card think about the future
on the streets of Gotham of what's
clearly a [ __ ] set
I uh I have two clerks three stories
from the last week
for example who went out and saw either
fathom or convenience to her I had
people from high school who stayed and
watched the credits who I haven't talked
to in 20 years messaged me and they were
like oh my God I saw your name in the
credits of Clerks three congrats uh but
the really cool one was
somebody I know who's on lucasfilm story
team went and saw it and he was like hey
how you doing uh I saw the scum and
villainy logo in clerks three and it
made me so happy
that's a blink and you miss it moment in
the movie but I've been at screenings
where people reacted to it I mean at the
premiere JC was like but I've been at
screenings in the real world where
people were like oh like somebody caught
in should people go Easter egg hunting
it's up there for like 32 frames or
something stupid but it's so fast it's
just Dante's walking into the Randall's
hospital room it's the last shot you see
on the TV before he sits down
um yeah I see you both every night on
tour every night I watch people [ __ ]
cheers from Mark because they're like
they've been like oh there he is the fat
man beyond guy and [ __ ]
um and they wait for him to talk and he
never does
um but uh yeah it's nice it's really
nice
um the feedback has been absolutely
[ __ ] wonderful like the fathom event
screenings allowed a lot of people to
see it and stuff and uh the reaction has
been overwhelmingly
um positive and and so thank you
everybody who engaged with clerks three
he made my dreams come true and if
you're one of those cats who was like
well I want Mall Rats well you might
have made them all right sequel [ __ ]
happen you made a manifest you might
have manifested that [ __ ] by patronizing
clerks three as you did because that's
the discussion we're having right now so
fingers crossed we get to we get to do
it man but it's uh been Bliss and I
invite all of you to come join me on the
road not for free give me your money but
uh clerks3 dot movie see where I am see
if I'm gonna be anywhere near you man
right now heading to California Los
Angeles get your [ __ ] tickets uh
lyrics Three dot movie Anaheim get your
[ __ ] tickets man it can't all be
about Mickey Mouse sometimes it's about
Kevin Smith
Clark's three dot movie
um but then after that we go to
I'm gonna come back out here I'm gonna
shoot a music video the same day that
we're doing this mod Castle we're
shooting a music video
uh out here and then um then I head up
to Toronto
for the Toronto shows there's two nights
in Toronto uh first night is practically
sold out second one is like half sold so
hey Toronto hop to it man get tickets
Clark's three times we go to Ottawa I
think that's sold out Montreal is not
sold out
um then we go to like uh
the Michigan area lots of it's great
it's really wonderful man I'll be on the
road for like the next two months man I
look forward to seeing not all of you
I'm sure some people like I'm here for
Bernard and [ __ ] your dumb ass in that
matter where's he gonna be yeah where's
Bernard
get out of the ways
he's gonna be one place in L.A one time
it's it's funny because it's true as
well
um yeah if you want to hang out with me
on the road for the next two months
clerks3.movie ladies and gentlemen or
next weekend in Jersey Jersey Babylon at
my movie theater at smodcast Castle
Cinemas oh my God somebody I was in the
in the theater today and two people left
like they went to the four o'clock clerk
show this couple and the one guy had a
mallrat shirt and I was like oh [ __ ] and
he saw me and it was like holy [ __ ] and
him and his lady we were chit chatting
for a minute and they were they're from
like the bro they came from down for
Brooklyn and they're like we saw your
Instagram post and we were like [ __ ] it
let's go watch the movie there and I was
like
I made [ __ ] twenty dollars Mark well
it was seven dollar Wacky Wednesday so
fourteen dollars by putting up that
[ __ ] Instagram post at my theater
alone man I see the results advertising
works that's like some Kardashian style
Instagram in it you're not kidding man I
say it they live it just like Kim
Kardashian I am a modern day Kim
Kardashian you are the influencer
uh no it's been it's been sweet though I
I do love haunting the theater
um you know like [ __ ] uh greeting
everybody as they come in hey how are
you welcome
yeah don't forget to dip you later
people are so nice they're like thanks
for thanks for buying this I was like
are you crazy
yeah what's up you know what you should
do there was a I think it was called
like jono Groats on Pico and Robertson
breakfast yeah
I think Greg grunberg was telling me
this story I guess he opened one up in
like Woodland Hills and such a big part
of it was like him standing there and
greeting people as they came in
and so he set up a webcam at the Pico
location that live streamed to the
Woodland Hills location
and he had a monitor so he could see
people coming in there that's what you
should do like you should set up like
Harley's old room in your house as like
a little greeting studio so you're like
oh I got 20 minutes go down to Harley's
old room and you could have a monitor
where you see people going into your
theater hey man it's me Kevin Smith oh
my God he recorded it no it's I'm
actually here
like you could talk to people as they
come into the theater from LA
don't [ __ ] tempt me with a good time
that sounds hot we can hook that up yeah
yeah yeah
done and done oh my God
that would be legit fun I'm telling you
when I'm here
I look forward to just going down and
introducing any movie
like not even mine just like oh you're
here to see the [ __ ] woman King well
let me tell you a little something about
Gina price Blackfoot whatever like you
got it I did thank you yeah
um I you know drop some trivia do a
little of that arc-like [ __ ] that was so
popular for so long until they went out
of business yeah not entirely the uh the
Hollywood location is going to come back
next year as an ArcLight as an ArcLight
well I'm stealing the idea anyway and
you can't that's fine I'm also stealing
the name tag things where you put your
favorite movie on it oh that's cool and
then my staff all of them will say
clerks
[Laughter]
um no what's your favorite movie Raising
Arizona clerks yeah I'm like you spelled
clerks wrong
um oh what Mary times these will be I
really you could say I'm very enthused
about this whole owning a movie theater
thing absolutely this look this is good
for critics everybody was like oh I hate
him and that [ __ ] most recent movie
reminds me why I hate him so much well
then then like sell out my events at the
theater because then I'll get distracted
from movies and I'll just become an
exhibitor and then you ain't got to
worry about ever having to sit through
some terrible Kevin Smith movie again
see it can all work out for everybody
everybody wins just like the ending of
Steel Magnolias
okay Daniel 01's just corrected I said
it is not coming back as an arc light
it's coming back but it's not going to
be an arclay so back to my original plan
I am stealing the idea
and not given the arc-like credit
because they don't exist anymore
I'm not entirely sure that DK Daniel o1
is correct but yeah right you got some
inside dope I mean I don't know I'm just
I've just read the news
can I just read you something from Josh
Cooper in chat he says I saw clerks
three two weeks ago and it's a great
movie Kevin I never cry watching
anything but I almost cried I lost my
dad a couple years ago to a heart attack
and it definitely hit close to home hmm
the clerks movie kids bring tissues
because you're gonna be like
oh and then later on you're like
yes so bring it an existential crisis
that is live so bring at least two
tissues yeah just two because you don't
want to reuse the same one anymore it's
too heavy and it's just Overkill you
only need two tissues in life just like
Douglas Adams taught us in the book you
only need a towel yeah
got both sides
that is deep cuts
uh kids normally we would do uh
Tim Daddio goes as Moser seen the movie
or signed a certain poster I don't think
I don't know I gotta ask him if you've
seen the movie but he's definitely not
signed the poster yet I'll get that
signed Tim don't you worry
um
uh Adam
gavaski says hey hey you didn't say hey
I had that but he says no shulky talk we
didn't talk about She-Hulk you caught up
uh I am [ __ ] up continues to be
wonderful I absolutely adore it
um I I was confused I thought we were
gonna get some Daredevil in the last
episode but that was not the case
because they teach this cow at the end
of one but he I thought the next week
this would be all DD but
it was all blue balls instead but um
it's uh it continues to please me I I
enjoy the [ __ ] out of it you
joined I didn't love the wedding episode
just because it it
I like that I like the the performer who
played the friend
yeah you know I mean it's it's one of
those things where what happened is
wasn't that great like oh yeah I get it
like her friend's an [ __ ] that wants
you to be Jen instead of She-Hulk
because she doesn't Shield because they
hold Thunder but there was no
comeuppance really for the friend and
for Jen to just continue to I don't know
Wallflower herself they it's I've seen
some version of that a hundred times
before
um I dubbed The Immortal man stuff that
was fun
um but yeah it uh I it's it's it's a
pleasure if not always a passion for me
uh it looks like the Arc Light is coming
back as Cinerama says trash Kanda
yeah because the Cinerama Dome can't
can't be torn down it's a it's a
landmark and so but I know that they
they are looking for or if not if they
haven't already acquired a liquor
license and they're completely redoing
the interior of that whether it's dark
lettuce and Ramadan either way
the space is back
um but we gotta let JC go Jason's got to
make it to the game he's got to go kids
we I can sit here and chit chat all
night but the guy who brings us to you
he's got a legitimate business to run
and stuff uh bam fan pop in here and say
goodbye to everybody
goodbye everybody take your lumps
there's your that's why we gotta stop
look at them
smug little [ __ ] Mohawks he's
he's Cobra Kai with the Eagles tattoo on
his chest and [ __ ]
just like that all over again he
threatened Mark the other day pushed him
up against the wall some dude in chat
was like bamf man's a tool
I guess I'm living my best life so sure
oh my God welcome to my world [ __ ]
that's been my life for the last 29
years me he like going I'm living my
best life it's some Rando on the
internet being you're a [ __ ] tool I'm
like I guess you're right
I guess I could be two things at once
first truths
um kids what a good time we've had
tonight
don't forget the most important thing we
talked about clerks three the community
tour rolling Across America uh check for
local listings or because it's still
playing there are movie theaters like
Regal just held the movie and started
playing that's awesome like it was a
grown ass movie and we didn't have to
pay we skipped all them charges and [ __ ]
uh so you Chuck fandango.com to see
where if clerks 3 is playing near you
and see it without me or come see it
with me on the convenience tour it's a
good time every night and [ __ ] like that
go to clerks3 dot movie thank you for
your time thank you uh for hanging out
with us this is nice I haven't done this
in a month welcome back I missed it yeah
it's nice it's good for the good bomb
Salve for the soul a fat man beyond here
we are doing it in a goddamn comic book
store here I'll give you 360 kids
look at this [ __ ]
look at that [ __ ] look at that [ __ ] I'm
alone in our comic book store look at
all this [ __ ]
look at all these fabulous prizes
alone in a store
alone in a store with my two big giant
pops so if I ever feel really alone I
can go [ __ ] that one I'd feel weird
[ __ ] him we're buddy but me [ __ ]
myself it'd be just like that recent
episode of Rick and Morty did you see
that [ __ ] I did not genius that's your
continues to me so absolutely [ __ ]
brilliant
um all right kids there it is uh Jesus
Christ
um
thank you for hanging out uh with us
here on fat man beyond and stuff uh but
there is no show without the the actual
smart guy I meet a lot of people on the
road Mark when we do uh the screenings
and we do VIP and with a hundred people
a night take pictures and stuff like
that and I honestly a good 30 to 40
percent of them are like I love fat man
beyond that's what got me through the
pandemic and my go-to deferral because I
don't take compliments well is like oh
if you like that show it's all because
of Mark Bernard and stuff and most
people like he is amazing one guy was
just like no way he hates everything I
love you
uh there it is my friends uh that's
that's it that's all we got that's all
we got yeah well I mean we got plenty
more but [ __ ] JC's got [ __ ] to do
[ __ ] busy I think I'm a [ __ ] C
character on the show and then he blows
us off go [ __ ] figure what are you
gonna do
good news is I kept the [ __ ]
intellectual rights to Banff man
when these things all over there'll be
another Banff man it may not be JC and
he'll have to become like
[ __ ] Camp man or something like that
skates close to my trademark
did you guys get Shaquille O'Neal to be
the new Batman yes we did I feel like
it's time to come in here Mohawk what do
you like what would be like bamf Wing
I'll like graduate
[Laughter]
uh Mo bamf or bamf Hawk I would vote
all right kids we're just being silly
um we don't mean uh Robin's stealing her
Muggin in fact don't take us seriously
we're only bugging
do do
old school kids
if you like this show it's because of
Mark Bernard give it up for Mr Mark
Bernard thank you Kevin Smith and uh
thank you to JC Banff man himself for
bringing us to you and [ __ ] the show is
at an end you're gonna have to figure
out what the [ __ ] else to do with the
rest of your Wednesday night man uh come
see me do Hollywood Babylon at my movie
theaters my castle Cinemas October 8th
in New Jersey
tickets at atlanticmoviehaus.com there
I'm done selling
uh thank you folks for hanging out uh
that
is fat man beyond for this evening tune
in next time same
fat Channel smodcast.com or youtube.com
Kevin Smith Jeff's kiss all over your
[ __ ] nipples kids
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Sal Bob get old off Kevin Smith
[Music]